[Music]  Kourtney Kardashian lifted up on  Sunday's Keeping Up with the Kardashians  the 38 year old reality star headed  south of the border to Mexico for a  birthday get away with friends her ex  Scott Disick had an interesting response  to Kourtney's hard-partying ways how  wasn't she's allowed to throw up in bed  and I like have to go to rehab if I do  something like that Scott also opened up  about Courtney's life apart from him I  get a little jealous because I think  that I wish we could have had some of  those type of times when we were  together at the end of the episode  Kourtney was clearly annoyed by Scotts  reaction he was jealous because we were  having fun  spending time with other people oh  that's really not fair  it's just like I can't even live my life  I can't even go anywhere he needs to get  a life and leave me alone  [Music]